كنا نتحدث للتو عن
وجهة نظر أخرى تمامًا للذكاء الاصطناعي وهي
الإمكانات التي يتمتع بها على سبيل المثال في مجال
الرعاية الصحية والاستخدامات الإيجابية الأخرى
هنا، لذا هنا لديك الجانب الآخر الذي
أفترض أنه يرسم خطوط الاتجاه هنا إلى
أقصى حد الانقراض  خطر أعني أنني
أتساءل عن حجم الخطر الذي
يتحدثون عنه هنا، هل هذا مجرد خطر
افتراضي، هل يقولون إنه
خطير للغاية؟ من الصعب، من الصعب
الموازنة بين كل ما تسمعه هنا لأن
شخصًا ما إيجابي للغاية والبعض الآخر سلبي للغاية، أليس كذلك؟
عبارة عن بيان قصير ولكن مثير للقلق
حول مخاطر الذكاء الاصطناعي من
العديد من الأشخاص الذين يقفون وراء تطوير
هذه التكنولوجيا، البيان قصير
يتكون من 22 كلمة يقرأها.
يجب أن يكون التخفيف من خطر الانقراض بسبب الذكاء الاصطناعي
أولوية عالمية إلى جانب المخاطر المجتمعية الأخرى
مثل الأوبئة و
الحرب النووية هذا بيان يقول
إن الذكاء الاصطناعي بحد ذاته يشكل خطر
الانقراض، ولا سيما الأشخاص الذين
وقعوا على هذه الرسالة هم بعض
المديرين التنفيذيين الذين بنوها بأنفسهم أشخاص
مثل سام ألتمان، الرئيس التنفيذي لشركة Open Mind،
لديك أشخاص من شركة Deepmind Google للذكاء الاصطناعي
على الرغم من وجود  كانت هناك بعض
الأسماء المفقودة البارزة من الرسالة،
مثل إيلون موسك الذي وقع على
خطاب سابق يقول إن الذكاء الاصطناعي بحاجة إلى
التوقف مؤقتًا لمدة ستة أشهر على الرغم من أن
شريكه غرايمز ونجم البوب ​​قد وقعا على
الرسالة الآن، فما هي المخاوف التي
أخبرها المنظمون وراء الرسالة
نيويورك تايمز أنه لم تكن هناك
تفاصيل على وجه التحديد في هذه الرسالة
لتوحيد المخاوف بشأن ما
يسمى بالأورام المختلفة التي يطلق عليها الذكاء الاصطناعي، ترى أن هذه
التكنولوجيا تشكل تهديدًا كبيرًا،
هناك مخاوف مثل المعلومات المضللة التي
نشهدها في انتخابات 2024 ولكن
بعد ذلك أيضًا  المزيد من
سيناريوهات Skynet الخيالية العلمية حيث يكون لديك ذكاء اصطناعي هارب
سيصبح أكثر ذكاءً
من البشر ولن نكون قادرين على
إيقاف تشغيل المفتاح، لقد تحدثت إلى أحد
المسؤولين التنفيذيين في مجال التكنولوجيا الذي يشاركني هذا الاعتقاد
وقال انظروا، النمور لديها أسنان أكثر حدة من البشر
يحتفظ البشر والبشر بالنمور في الأقفاص وحدائق
الحيوان، والسبب في أننا أكثر ذكاءً
منهم، حسنًا، إذا أصبح الذكاء الاصطناعي أكثر ذكاءً من
البشر ولم نتمكن من السيطرة عليهم،
فلا يوجد ما يقول ما سيحدث
بعد ذلك